[Music]
now
we will go to anna who is connected
for an announcement about our
partnership with
acp countries
ana we can hear you go ahead
okay thanks uh sorry i'm just getting
this right
hi you can hear me
can you hear me yes we can hear you anna
aye
sorry thank you so um yesterday um
as you probably have seen commissioner
for international partnerships
uh uw lineup and the foreign minister of
togo robert
ducey the chief negotiators from the eu
and the organization of african
caribbean and pacific states
reached a political agreement on the
text for a new partnership agreement
that will succeed
the cotton agreement this first
important milestone paves the way now
for
formal conclusion of the agreement in
january the agreement will still have to
be approved signed
and ratified by the parties and the new
agreement covers a large number of areas
from sustainable development
uh growth to human rights peace and
security
and it will better equip the eu and the
oacp uh
member countries to address together the
emerging challenges
and uh global challenges such as the uh
19 pandemic
climate change ocean uh governance
migration peace and security issues
um taking very much into account uh the
specific needs of each
region um the agreement um has a common
foundation that sets out
the values and principles and strategic
priorities and also regional protocols
with their own specific governance to
manage and steer
relations uh with the eu and the
different regions involved
um through joint uh parliament uh
committees including
um there would also be an overarching uh
jones
oacps eu framework with a strong
parliamentary dimension
and um i think it's important to say
that at the heart of this new
partnership
um will be the 2030 agenda for
sustainable
development and the paris agreements
once in effect um the agreement will
serve as the new legal framework to
guide the political economic
and corporation relations between the eu
and the 79 members
of the oacps for the next 20 years
that was a bit long but it's an
important it's an important
agreement that we will now hopefully be
able to conclude in the next coming
weeks
thank you very much anna indeed well
worth it this is an important milestone
in our relations with acp countries this
brings us to the end of our
announcements
for today and therefore we will now take
your questions and i see that odile
has asked for the floor
um
brexit
[Music]
[Music]
please only keep your hand raised if it
is on
the negotiations
[Music]
thank you eric i have a question for uh
for peter it's regarding belgrade in the
dialogue
president of serbia announced a new
round of dialogue for
next thursday so can peter just confirm
what will be the agenda and the question
is
is eu as a main facilitator
agreed with priesthina to come back on
the issue of
municipalities of serbian municipalities
thank you
thank you pass the floor to peter
thanks good afternoon ew is the
facilitator of the dialogue and
is organizing the meetings both at
expert level or
at the higher political level regularly
we always announce these meetings
including the agenda a few days before
they are supposed to
um take place so that's on the overall
logistics of announcements and
uh on your question indeed i can confirm
that uh
there is an idea to have the meeting at
the level of chief negotiators
in brussels in person next thursday
on the second part of your question the
agenda as i said we will
announce the agenda closer to the date
of the meeting
thank you are there other questions for
peter on this dialogue
or more generally on foreign relations
so in foreign relations nicola
uh hello actually it's a question more
for ana
than for peter actually made the
situation in serbia is getting worse
independent journalists from n1 and nova
s televisions are under strong political
attack for years
uh it escalated in the parliament when
ruling party
members of the parliament stating that
those media are undisturbed in media and
anti-state constructions
accusing the media to create the
atmosphere in which president of serbia
can be killed
uh journalists are labeled in the
parliament as traitors
and foreign mercenaries and this is not
the first time
the independent journalists are targets
and under attacks by members of
parliament or
the government or even the president of
serbia uh those last
attacks i have to say that came right
after the president of serbia
accused united group one of the largest
investors in the eu
uh in which those tv stations operate
for for wasting millions of euros
investing in serbian media
that run the campaign against him and
gave advice to kill him
uh instead so i would like to uh
to hear what can european commission do
regarding this issue
besides noting down in reports that the
situation in serbia
is not that bad is bad because we know
that
uh even in the last european uh
commission report is
basically that something that has been
done in on the protection
of journalists so um what can european
commission do regarding this issue and
can
uh can european union undertake any
specific step to pressure serbia as a
negotiating country
to fulfill its obligations towards eu
because the safety of journalists
is one of those obligations thank you
thank you very much i will give the
floor to anna
hello do you hear me yes i know we hear
you go ahead
okay thank you um so thanks uh very much
uh
nicola for the question um i think that
um you know it's it's first important
to set the position of the european
union which is very clear
in terms of uh you know we condemn uh
any attacks
or threats against uh journalists um for
us
it's clear that it it's crucial that
journalists are able to do their job
uh free of any threat of violence
harassment
and intimidation to ensure that citizens
of course
have access to all information
we welcome the authorities condemnation
of these attacks and threats we do
expect
uh also serbia to create an enabling
environment
in which uh freedom of expression uh can
be exercised
without hindrance um this um
issue is is addressed in the the media
strategy that the serbian
government has put forward and in the
action plan
that the government adopted yesterday um
for us we welcome very much uh
this adoption and um we call on serbia
to
uh uh to uh swift uh implementation
in a transparent and uh inclusive uh
manner
um we expect that the new working group
uh for
uh safety of uh journalists uh to
continue to ensuring
uh an effective judicial follow-up uh on
all instances of physical and uh
verbal uh violence against journalists
um
you know very well that um you know for
us media freedom and media pluralism
are our essential aspects uh uh
and and they're really in europe's uh
dna so
i think that is our uh position
thank you anna and i would add that this
morning the president had
a meeting by a video conference with
the serbian prime minister mrs anna
vernabic
during which she congratulated her for
her re-election
and among the issues that were raised
were of course the negotiation
due negotiations on accession and the
rule of law chapter
and in this context the issue of media
freedom came up and the
and mrs vanovich gave reassurances to
the president of the commission
that the government would undertake what
was necessary to
ensure media freedom in serbia
are there other questions for anna today
that does not seem to be the case so i
open the floor to
other issues and we go to
duarte
all right hello can you hear me yes well
yeah okay
thanks uh i have a question on
competition and
um the investigation the commission's
investigation on moderate
island free zone state eight uh did this
investigation concludes that the heads
were not implemented according to
approved conditions i wonder if you
could elaborate a little bit more on
this
and and what are the next steps thanks
okay thank you we therefore
will open this chapter
so i passed the floor to ayanna
hi can you hear me yes go ahead
okay thanks indeed uh today we have
adopted a decision
concluding that the medea free zone
scheme was not implemented in line with
the approved conditions
uh of course the condition the
commission fully recognizes the
outermost
region nature of madeira and the need
to provide regional aid to the companies
operating in it in order to attract
investment
this is why in 2007 and 2013 the
commission has adopted
decisions approving the madeira free
zone
however when verifying the
implementation
of the conditions of the scheme the
commission has seen that two fundamental
conditions in particular were not
being respected in some of the cases one
was the jobs created or maintained had
to be
in the island of madeira while instead
we have seen that some of these jobs
accounted for when when calculating the
amount of aid were actually in other
eu member states or even outside the eu
and the other condition was that the
activity for which
the tax reductions were being granted
had to take place in madeira
again this was not the case therefore
the decision concerns the measures that
did not bring
value added to the island of madeira
itself
now the commission is requiring portugal
to recover
the illegal aid granted which does not
mean that all companies that have
benefited from the scheme have to
recover the aid
it means that the companies that did not
respect the compatibility conditions of
jobs and
profit um in the region of madeira will
have to
recover this aid first of all these
conditions will have to be checked
second portugal will have to see whether
the amounts of aid granted are
below the 200 000 over three years the
minimum threshold
and at that point we will know which
companies have to recover the aid and
for which amount
thank you there is a follow-up question
go ahead
okay now i mean uh sorry just a quick
follow-up to
to to let me know if you have an idea of
the amount of aids that are uh
irregular let's say so thanks
oh yeah
sorry i was speaking without pressing
the speak button
so um unfortunately no we don't have an
idea of the number of companies
concerned or the amounts of aid to be
recovered
because as i was mentioning portugal
will really now have to see
which companies did not respect these
two compatibility conditions of jobs
created in the regions
and activities for which the tax
reductions are being granted in the
region of madeira
once this list will be complied they
will have to see how many of these
companies
have received eight amounts which are um
above
the the the minimum threshold and only
at that point
uh we will know uh the amounts
what i can say perhaps just to give a
bit of a parameter but is of course a
general uh
figure is that there are 1 700
registered entities that are benefiting
that have benefited from from this
measure between 2007
and 2014 and we believe that only 300 of
them
have benefited from an amount above
200 000 euros of these 300 of course
portugal now will have to do the checks
on the compatibility conditions
thank you ariana are there other
competition related questions
for ariana today please only keep your
hand raised if it is
well first let's focus on this
portuguese issue on this portuguese case
so please only keep your hand raised if
it is on this mosey i know your question
is not on this voila susana
yes a follow-up um just to understand so
if
a company um received illegal
aid but the threshold is um
below 200 000 euros
that's okay so in that case even if the
received aid
is illegal they don't have to return it
to
to to to the to the state so that's my
uh
first question and uh how are you sure
if you don't have this uh relation
between
which countries are supposed to give the
money back
how how do you know how many are above
200 000 euros i'm not sure if i'm i'm
very
very i'm being clear but i'm still
trying to understand also this uh
this document thank you in this decision
go ahead but press speak first
yes i should have learned by now almost
there
uh indeed so uh on the 200 000 over
three years threshold
this um relates to the de minimis
regulation
which says that aid to a company
below this amount over three years is
actually not considered to be state aid
as it has not
an impact on um on trade in the internal
market
and this is why uh it's it's not
considered at a
as aid ever in in an application of
stated rules and clearly as it is a
general principle
it applies for uh this case as well the
the figures i was giving are just
indicative uh so so they were just to
give
an idea of the size and they were based
on exchanges that we have had
in the past with the portuguese
authorities and on on our uh analysis
but of course when we monitor cases
which is something that the commission
does regularly
it selects each case each year a number
of cases uh to to verify if they have
been implemented
uh in accordance in accordance with the
compatibility conditions
it selects you know some companies that
to to
to verify in in greater detail and what
has happened in this case
is that for a number of these companies
we have seen that the clear
compatibility conditions of value added
for the region of madeira specifically
had not been
fulfilled and for this reason we we have
taken this decision today
thank you now unfortunately i have the
impression
that susana could not hear the answer
suzanna i propose uh if that is the case
that you watch the answer on ebs after
the
after the midday or that you contact
ayanna
bilaterally on your question are there
other competition related questions
for ariana today tommaso
yes good morning chronos thank you for
the floor it's just
a question about fincantieri and
santiago atlantique
it's for ariana it's on uh
fincantierishanted
atlantique because
i would ask ariana if she can provide us
i mean an update on the case because
there are some
complaints by italian politicians they
say that the commission is going to
shoot the the merger because france
doesn't uh he is not in favor of it
there are
a lot of uh i mean there's much talking
in italy it would be helpful if you can
have an update on this
thank you ariana
thanks eric and then hi tommaso the the
update
is unfortunately that there is no update
on
on our side let me recall you what the
situation on fincan theory is
so on the 13th of march 2020 so this
year
the commission has stopped the clock in
the in-depth investigation
of the acquisition of chantilly antique
by
fincantieri and the clock remains
stopped
just to remind you this procedure in
merger investigations
is activated by the commission each time
that the parties fail to provide
in a timely manner an important piece of
information that the commission has
requested
from them in view of course of its
ongoing
investigation you know to comply with
the merger deadlines the parties must
submit the necessary information
to the commission in a timely manner if
they don't do so the commission will
eventually stop the clock and as soon as
the missing information
are provided by the parties the stock
the clock is restarted and
the commission investigation continues
with the deadline adjusted accordingly
thank you very much ayan i can imagine a
room full of clocks being started and
stopped
depending on the cases so are there
other questions on competition for
ariana today
stefan in christian conference
to find the source of micro
[Music]
j
a
i have a question on european for
european diplomacy
what are their actions in defense of
human rights of the grey people because
they are very alarming reports
coming from sudan uh from sudanese
military
and international ngos who are at border
uh
including uh the european uh union are
ngos that are the army of
our federal troops federal troops of
ethiopia
doesn't allow the refugees to cross the
border
and my question is i repeat it what is
what are the actions of the eu
diplomacy to ensure right to life
of these people and right to free
movement um i hope that
there is um um nabil is there
to answer my question thank you anna as
i said
very often we provide a constant service
so nabila is here of course good
afternoon
and thank you for your question
let me remind you first that respect for
human rights and fundamental freedoms
are
essential elements of eu's foreign
policy and in particular the cotunu
agreement between the eu and the acp
countries
including ethiopia in this vein the
european union is committed
to support ethiopia to protect respect
and promote human rights including
through its political dialogue with the
government
development cooperation support to civil
society and capacity building
it is clear that human rights and
international humanitarian law
must be held upheld under all
circumstances
and any violations be accounted for in
line with international standards
and instruments we as
i said before we are following the
situation in ethiopia
with great attention and coordinating
very closely with regional
and international actors our message is
clear
and focused on the session on the
secession of hostilities
and of the ethnic targeted violence
protection of civilians
in particular idps and refugees
returned to dialogue with a strong
support given to the au
initiative we hope that all parties will
listen
to the sustained and concerted call we
have not
only be vocal by but also
active in our outreach at political and
humanitarian level
needless to remind you the efforts of
the hrvp
borrel who has met with deputy prime
minister
and minister of foreign affairs of
ethiopia
with and he had talked also with the
prime minister
uh with the chairman of igad and
with the chairperson of the african
union
musafaki and the hrvp expressed the eu's
support to any initiatives of egad and
the african union to address the
situation
he also made clear that the engagement
of the high-level envoys
appointed by the chair of the african
union should open the door for a
dialogue
that is the only way forward to avoid
further destabilization
and also i would like to remind you that
the commissioner linacich traveled to
ethiopia
and to the border area in eastern sudan
on the first
on first to third december he met
sudanese prime minister
and he the head of the civilian-led
transaction
transitional government abdullah hamdug
and muhammad al-taishi
of the sovereign council as well as the
representatives of the humanitarian
organization
he also invited he also visited
the um rakuba camp in eastern sudan
where more
than forty thousand forty five thousand
refugees have arrived over the past few
years
a few weeks uh on his way to sudan the
commissioner also met with ethiopian
minister for peace
mufira kamil and inadi
during these meetings the commissioner
emphasized the importance that
humanitarian workers have
unrestricted access to all areas
affected by fighting
he also urged the authorities to allow
the evacue
the evacuation of the remaining eu
citizens from the conflict affected
areas in tigre thank you very much
nabila for
this uh extensive answer to the question
are there other questions for nabila
on africa
are there other questions for labilla in
general on her portfolio
nawab
yes thank you sorry my camera is not
working today
i have a question on afghanistan and
i would like to ask your reaction to
the recent agreement between
taliban and the afghanistan government
to continue peace talks thank you
thank you very much indeed a question
for
nabila
thanks a lot nawab
as you can see i'm lost in my papers
what i can tell you is that we take note
is yes i do but sometimes i need to be a
bit more uh
but anyways um i would like to tell you
that we do
we do take a note of the of the
agreement
that you have just
mentioned and
as you know we had it it comes at a very
timely time that we had
the conference on afghanistan just
in the past in a few a few weeks back
and that we are following and looking
forward to
a piece but we we have to first
see what is in this in this agreement so
this is what i have to say on this
thank you very much other other
questions for nabila today
that does not seem to be the case
so let's see if stefan has
managed to switch mike source you had a
question on competition i believe
you have no mic at all i'm said i'm told
stefan so i would ask you to contact us
bilaterally after the midday briefing
please
mosey over to you
yes thank you eric i have a
kind of follow-up questions to
yesterday's discussion
about traveling during the holiday and
christmas period
i think that commission has referred to
traveling advice given by the two eu
agencies this week
saying that it's not such a high risk to
travel
but my question is besides that
it seems that the commission also has
taken some exceptional measures
somehow to encourage its own staff
to travel home during this period i
think about this measure which was
discussed yesterday about
clothing european schools two weeks
before christmas and secondly
to allow commission staff to be
teleworking
from abroad which is quite exceptional
so how to explain these two measures
thank you thank you mosey i will give
the floor
to balash on your on your question
hi good afternoon jose so uh
first of all on uh giving the
possibility to our staff members to to
telework from outside the duty station
this is an exceptional measure as you
know working outside the duty
uh station is in principle and
in general forbidden unless there are
some exceptional circumstances at play
such as family reasons for example now
in the context of christmas
and bearing in mind the fact that the
vast majority of our staff
are expats meaning that their duty
station
is outside their country of origin for a
very specific
limited amount of time we will make it
possible this is by no means an
obligation this is a possibility
for those staff members who can also
secure the agreement of their superiors
and whose work in terms of the nature of
their work is compatible
with this measure they can be authorized
exceptionally for a period of of two
weeks
um in the run after the christmas period
to work outside the
duty duty station now why
why do we do this we have to bear in
mind as well that
when returning to their families staff
members would often have to
observe guarantee measures therefore
it would be it would be impossible for
them to be reunited with their families
if they arrive just before christmas
therefore this measure will give the
opportunity the possibility for those
staff members who can
again secure who can fit all the
criteria
to clear carrying requirements upon
arrival
in their member state by the time
christmas comes and then
be reunited with their family members
thank you i think that stefan wants to
add something on european schools
or in schools in general actually
yes thank you very much eric i indeed
wanted to add something just to make
sure there's a clear understanding of
what the staying stage strategy
mentions about schools to start with i
think eric you have explained very well
yesterday that we're talking about
recommendations here
now when it comes to schools the
recommendation does not say that schools
have to be closed i would like to make
that very clear
what recommendation says that we want to
reduce
transmission risks in a period following
the festive season
there is a risk of transmission we need
to follow the method of the
the three c's as you know avoid crowded
spaces
avoid close contacts and closed uh
spaces and it's in order to avoid or to
reduce rather
such transmission risks that
recommendation
invites the member states to consider
extending school holidays or introducing
periods of online learning so it's very
important that the focus of the
recommendation is
on taking actions to avoid transmission
and it's in that perspective
that this recommendation has been made
thank you
thank you thank you other questions on
this
on this issue tom
welcome back
tom you have the floor go ahead
okay
okay can you hear me we can see you and
hear you go ahead tom
okay fine it's on north stream too
um sorry tom we're not i'm sorry
we're not on that issue for the moment
okay we're talking about something
different
thanks david
i believe he's on this issue
david
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stefan
is
[Music]
[Music]
um
are you still with us i can see you on
the list
yes okay it's a question for christian
um you know that now there is a new
proposal of the spanish government
to the exchange of reforming the
judicial power
taking into account that some weeks ago
the first proposal receives your
critics i would like to know now if you
have information about the new proposal
and which is your reaction thank you
indeed for christian
hi hi xiaomi thank you for the question
um as you will
remember we had expressed a clear
position
that it is important for spain to
address the issue of
the judicial council and at the same
time to ensure
that the judicial council is not
perceived as vulnerable
to politicization we are aware
of the new proposal and it is important
that member states
when reforming their judicial system
carry out the necessary consultations if
all necessary
with all the stakeholders all the
relevant stakeholders and with the
venice commission
member states must follow european
standards to ensure
that judicial independence is not
compromised
we will continue to follow the situation
closely and we await more information
from the spanish government
thank you very much are there more
questions for christiane
on ah jean you have a follow-up go ahead
just when you mention stakeholders
you've been to your position
or what do you mean exactly
when i say all relevant stakeholders
then i mean all relevant stakeholders
that includes of course relevant
stakeholders in the in the political
sphere but also in the judicial sphere
thank you author xiaomi one last
follow-up on this one
it's okay it's okay
do we have other questions on this issue
of the
spanish law reforming the
judicial council i see
nacho
nacho go ahead do you hear me yes
um hi thank you for for the reply to
jonah's question
um i i would like to know if i think
that
was last week uh commissioner reinders
talked with
the spanish minister of justice and they
talk about the
the judicial reform so i would like to
know
if uh mr campbell told uh
anything related within this new
proposal to the commissioner
and if not uh if there is
some uh loss of trust between the
the the european commission and and and
the
justice uh minister because it seems
that they are
proposing again this uh this
new reform that it seems that you you
criticize again
um yes there was indeed an online
meeting last week between the
commissioner and the
spanish justice minister which was a
constructive
exchange on different issues on
[Music]
first of all on the european public
prosecutor which the commissioner has
spoken with many ministers in in recent
days
to ensure that it can swiftly start and
also on some other issues
including rule of law the rule of law
report and also the issue of the
judicial council
was addressed and
the minister also assured the
commissioner that
the necessary consultation with the
venice commission
would take place and we will of course
continue to working
constructively in the context with
with the government on this issue
thank you nacho you have a follow-up
yeah very quick uh follow-up uh so so
he says that uh any new reform will will
take into account the
[Music]
all the necessary measures i want to
know if
after this new proposal do you think
that
is fulfilling the
[Music]
make you're breaking up nacho but i
think
we got the gist of your of your question
related to the uh adequacy of the new
proposal
uh i think i know the answer that
question will give go ahead
yes i think i think i've said everything
that i can say i
expressed the position about this now
and that it is of course important
to consult and we will continue to work
constructively with our counterparts
remember that we do not pass judgment on
draft
laws we reiterate from time to time here
general principles that are important
and that apply horizontally and are of
course relevant for the
for the case in point i see no further
questions
for christian today so
tom we come back to you with your
question on north stream too
um
[Music]
peter
peter can you connect please if not we
will come back to you
bilaterally there seems to be an issue
with
with peter's connection
so let's move on to other issues tom uh
i will ask
um peter to come back to you and if
anybody else is interested in the answer
to that question
please contact contact
it's crazy friday
peter i believe it's best if you go back
bilaterally to
to tom and anybody else who contacts you
let us move on to other issues
yogi you have the floor
actually i was
i was inspired by
tom's question about pipelines but
my question was on a different pipeline
and it's probably for team
the trans-adriatic pipeline has
started delivering gas and i'm not
aware of any eu
reaction uh on this account
and i would like to know what does the
commission think about the completion of
this project
so that has taken so many years
which brings gas from
azerbaijan to the european union in an
effort to
diversify the supplies thank you
indeed tim
the top pipeline
thanks yogi for for your question indeed
it was something you you'd raised
um with me by email and i was just ready
with a reply which i was going to send
to you
after the midday but i'd be happy to
read it out for you on the on the podium
as well
so what i can tell you is that the the
commission welcomes the start of
operation of the the transat
adriatic pipeline which connects greece
to italy through albania
to bring caspian natural gas to
consumers in the eu
the project would increase choice and
competition improve energy security
and diversify gas supply in particular
in italy greece and bulgaria
as well as in the the southeast european
region
tapas as you will know is a project of
common interest
and together with the already completed
transanatonium pipeline
is an important part of the southern gas
corridor
thank you very much other questions for
tim on
energy
tom you still have your hand raised
but as i said we will come back to you
bilaterally on the
on that issue but do you have perhaps
another question
yes
tom i don't know no
i don't have another question okay then
please on raise your hand
thank you christian
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we still love you christian as i said in
my tweet
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
we come back to you
yes good morning thank you and uh sorry
for taking advantage of you but
it's just on vaccines if amy from stefan
it's just no uh i mean the contracts
which have been signed with the
manufacturers are still
confidential which is understandable
because you are still negotiating with
norwax if i'm not
mistaken i wonder just if the commission
is going
to publish them at least partially
in the next weeks when the negotiations
the negotiations with the nova packs
will be over
because i hear repeated
claims of transparency but
on vaccines there are i mean
confidentiality issues which
uh which hinder transparency
and i just like to have an update on
this thank you
i don't think there is any update
tommaso compared to the many times
that we've answered this question here
on the on the podium
it's not a question necessarily only of
time but i will give the floor to
stefan to provide you with the elements
uh thank you very much tommaso you are
right that
some of the information in this
countries is indeed covered by
confidentiality clauses you know also
the reasons
why this is so among other things to
also protect
and make sure the negotiations that are
ongoing with other
companies can take place in a correct
way maybe
what i would like to reiterate is the
fact
that this question of confidentiality
was also raised in european parliament
and the european commissioner ke
akires has said that we
are ready to explore within contractual
constraints
making information from contracts
available
to nominated members of the parliament
with specific arrangements
once these sensitive ongoing
negotiations are concluded
this is as you know worded in very
careful wording
exactly based on the fact that the
elements in this contract are covered by
confidentiality obligations
thank you thank you and let me add thank
you
that we should not forget that the
member states
uh all have uh full access to the
contracts indeed they were
part and parcel of the negotiation
process they were
members of the negotiation teams that
negotiated and are
still negotiating these contracts
and they have the information on the
contract so
of course the the commission is not
withholding this information
from um from the member states we are
one uh team
and um the information is available
in its entirety to the member states
are there other questions for us today
i do not see any so let me wish you an
excellent
weekend and i look forward to seeing you
again here in the press room on monday
thank you